n
attend la saison 2022 pour
remettre le paquet.
- Qu'est-ce qui se cache
derrière le succès d'Elon Musk,
Jeff Besos ou Mark Zucherberg?
Jusqu'où faut-il être prêt
à aller pour réussir?
C'est la question que pose
"Manuel de la vie sauvage".
ISABEAU BLANCHE, comédienne
"Manuel de la vie sauvage"
- C'est très animal, c'est
très instinctif, c'est d'aller
écraser pour obtenir ce qu'on
veut. C'est très...
C'est la jungle.
- Sans haine, je serais pas
devenue entrepreneure.
Sans haine, je serais pas
devenue qui je suis!
- "Manuel de la vie sauvage" est
l'adaptation théâtrale du roman
Guérard. Ici, pas de nature mais
bien la jungle moderne des start
ups.
EMMANUELLE LUSSIER MARTINEZ
comédienne "Manuel de la vie
sauvage"
- Dans la cruauté humaine aussi,
ça nous ramène souvent à ça,
jusqu'où t'es prêt à aller pour
survivre ou, justement, pour
réussir, dans ce cas-ci.
Le premier pas vers la
trahison, c'est la confiance.
- À la manière d'une conférence
de motivation de type Ted Talk,
l'entrepreneuse québécoise
Cindy Berard, créatrice d'une
application révolutionnaire,
raconte de manière totalement
décomplexée son parcours
impitoyable.
- Elle le fait effectivement
en toute transparence.
- Oui.
- Oui, comme quoi tout les
moyens sont bons.
- Oui, la fin justifie les
moyens. Il y a plein... Je pense
aux Fables de La Fontaine.
- Vous êtes deux estis de
crosseurs!
- Contrairement au roman, le
personnage principal de la pièce
est une femme de pouvoir. Un
choix qui n'est pas anodin et
qu'assume le metteur en scène.
JEAN-SIMON TRAVERSY, codirecteur
artistique, Théâtre Jean-Duceppe
- Si on avait voulu écrire le
personnage pour une héroine,
pour une femme, mais si on
l'écrit d'une certaine manière,
donc pour un gars, et puis qu'à
la fin, on prend du recul puis
on fait juste changer, on se
rend contre que le parcours est
beaucoup plus riche et puis on
fait dire quelque chose.
- Le monde s'imagine que je suis
juste un genre de mécène
"fucking" riche.
- Comme c'est contre-balancé
avec d'autres portraits
de femmes en affaires,
on a vraiment un panel hyper
intéressant de femmes de tête,
de femmes de carrière, mais très
différentes.
- Tu devrais être juste un peu
plus comme moi, puis un peu
moins comme toi.
- "Manuel de la vie sauvage" est
une satire cynglante et un guide
impitoyable pour survivre dans
un monde cruel, parce que
l'humain est un animal,
un animal sauvage.
- Toutes les relations humaines
sont des transactions.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.